donne-moi quelques années
de cette ville
[Musique]
à 26 ans j'ai prêté serment tu sais celui qu'on
m'a demandé si ce que j'ai fait valait
25 ans
maintenant je vais voir si c'était
blanc et frais je veux que tu le fasses  allez à
Tulsa
tu es sérieux
tu as besoin d'un chat alors je suis allé voir le patron tu peux
courir comme un fou faire ce que tu
veux j'ai besoin de voir tes livres êtes-vous
du gouvernement je viens de vous
assommer et vous pensez que je suis un CPA
am  Je suis accusé d'avoir failli me faire
tirer dessus parce que je ne pense pas que ce soit un
crime, même dans l'Oklahoma,
qu'est-ce qu'un ex-mafia Capo va à Tulsa
et j'ai pensé que tu serais le
deuxième à savoir que je suis très excité
Amigo tu es  précisément où tu es
censé être si tu travailles pour moi nous gagnerons de
l'argent remettons les premières
discothèques une discothèque tu es un
sarcastique un petit avantage tu ne
me donnes pas quelques années
je veux posséder cette ville
si  quelqu'un vous demande ce que je fais dans la
vie, dites-leur que je suis un industriel,
qu'est-ce que cela signifie
exactement pour moi
[Musique]